so Jason I'm gonna start with you
because you were involved with the
screenplay of the film and so I just
wanted to talk a little bit when did you
first become acquainted with this
project and how did you be were you
invited by West to join in or was it
something you were talking about
together what was the initial well I
I can't specifically remember the exact
it's a little foggy exactly but I do
remember that when we started I had a
daughter and now the movies come out and
I have another daughter and a son and
that's so was it it was quite some time
ago and um I believe it was almost five
years ago or four years ago and Wes Wes
came to he was talking to Roman and I
yeah I mean I don't know he wasn't like
can you come over here right now I've
got something to talk to you about it
was it just came up you know in
conversation and he said I've got an
idea I want to do a movie that
stop-motion with five dogs who are alpha
dogs they named them and there's trash
and and that's all I've got right now
and it sounded and you stayed true to
that yes yes and I I just I was excited
to to do it to try to figure figure out
what it was that you know Wes had a I
mean he had like three those three
little primary ingredients and but a
feeling about it and it was one trash
and trash so what was the writing
process like then did you yeah I
understand there was a little bit of a
writers room type thing when he brought
out some other people and is that right
or well you know it was Wes Kuhn Roman
and myself and I mean it began really
the writing process Wes lives overseas
most of the time I live here and Roman
lives in San Francisco and Kuhn lives in
Japan so there was quite a lot of
planning right oft but I think the most
interesting thing about it for me is how
Wes he wanted to write he did the whole
thing chronologically scene by scene
with there was no outline there was no
hole
for the for the film we really had
there's dogs trash stop-motion and then
building it and building it building it
like for instance when Ataris plane
crashes in the we didn't know that we'd
actually meet Atari until his plane
crashed do you know I mean like so there
was no grand outline like now we but now
is when he comes in it we would sit
there and we would just Wes this just
just works non-stop and it did you all
do it over the phone
did you do it yeah email phone and we
would go to we Roman and I would fly to
to Paris or to England and we'd say
there for like three weeks at a time
oh my goodness sounds horrible and we
travel yeah and and we uh yeah it's
really just all day working in a room
and asking each of these questions and
then it starts to happen like you get
one idea and then it it leads to
something and wes is the filmmaker he's
sort of a guiding light like we're
almost asking him what about this what
about that and then when something feels
right all these ideas start to happen
what a wonderful what a wonderful thing
that to trust a people that you trust so
much that you can go in with just a
basic idea and know that the four of you
four yeah four of you would work would
be able to work out the rest of it I
mean what does that to me that's that's
entirely magical but you know how that
you greatest it's the bet it's wonderful
cuz those people specifically those are
because right no I'm not afraid Trumpy
myself yeah that I'm they have seen some
great moments for me and some terrible
moments for me and so there's nothing to
be ashamed of right when you go to work
every day it's just there's no literally
you just got to go for it
some would win like here we're full of
shame
and they act out the stuff that's a big
part of it too is that you so you're
acting it out them yeah we start to
write out the scenes then we start to
play these characters like to see that
I'd like to see that too
I can't do that nobody was filming that
ha nobody was filming no nobody was
filming it's a picture so but you don't
bet he took any picture told me I would
have been there I got photos Courtney
you you did not see the script did you
you were just the narrator what did you
know and what did he say as far as when
he said Weston I worked about 1993 at
Sundance lamp and so it was he called me
and I was so happy to you know I've
always wanted to crack into this this
voiceover animated world it's very tough
nut to crack these days and so so he
called me and I jumped and I can't
remember Jason if I if I read the script
it was a while ago I can't remember
where where did you record biloba ginkgo
biloba oh you're talking about something
Anka biloba is there memory memory they
take that's something else that's
something I recommend the studio was
somewhere in Burbank so were you all my
unit right okay go below go to stage
three that's crazy
who are you all by yourself when you
record it absolutely me and and what was
Western West may have been in Japan or
somewhere probably in England in England
so if we were over the phone and it took
us a minute because you know he had a
very particular vision of what the
narrator's supposed to sound like and I
thought I knew I saw the copy I said I
know how to do this I know what this is
and then he said no that's like you read
it out loud
rhythm my rhythm you know but but that's
that this wasn't the rhythm of the piece
and so we had to work do you know Jeff
Jeff we had to work together we had that
Jack made the work together but you are
your voiceover we haven't told you it's
so beautiful I mean the whole movie
trust Wes but he uses us also so
beautifully but your
voiceover is particularly grabbed well
it has a beautiful gravitas and and I
think I had a cold it sounds like a cool
whatever whatever great no but I didn't
sound like that initially what do you
say - you said you have a sort of a do
you know a movement to it it moved
orgeous and something about your s's
don't you go I love dogs
something so a dog or something I'm
gonna I'm gonna work on that Jeff I
understand that you recorded your
sequencing or your voice over an
entirely different way word that were
you hearing other people and where were
you and how did that work I was he asked
me to go to this lovely session sounded
like a lovely session because I love
interaction you know and Bob Balaban and
Bill Murray and Ed Norton and Bryan
Cranston all us dogs were gonna be in
New York and I couldn't go scheduling I
didn't allow me to go so I did my part
all by myself at a recording studio
somewhere near here gingko biloba know
and EMS was not was not pray he was in
other way he was in New York I think and
I just realized I thought he was on a
phone but he was in at the record some
kind of recording studio in a booth
Jeremy Dawson told me one of the other
producers very concentrated on you know
and it felt like a very intimate and
delightful work session between us he's
spectacular you know as you know and uh
that's what we that's what we did and
then I never saw him that's the last and
then he would send me here Jeremy was he
a med uh-huh didn't even see him then
didn't see him then and then and I
hadn't talked to him on the phone before
then he'd only sent me the script that
he mailed me and then a couple of times
later during the process they'd he
mailed me and said hey can you record on
your iphone this line again or another
line like this that I did and then it
wasn't till the movie was done and we
went on this publicity little endeavor
that we're doing now we went to Berlin
he won the Best Director award in Berlin
and then we won the then we went to
South by Southwest and won the favorite
audience movie that I did I did uh but
that's the first time I saw him or any
other actor in the movie
there's a very precise rhythm and timing
to his films so I'm just curious when
he's putting pieces like this together
what are the things that that get that
rhythm
how does he achieve that rhythm or what
are the things that you notice well I
know what as I said with the narration I
thought I had an idea of what you know
the pace of it but I had to really just
put my oh that's not it
okay um but where are we at Westwood you
know so we did we did the first half of
it and we got a kind of got a rhythm and
then we did the second half of it
thinking that we had the first half down
we did the second half but the second I
was when I think he really found the
voice the the rhythm of the narrator and
he said okay we've so we finished it and
then he said let's go back and do the
first half over again with the second
half rhythm that we found and I said God
okay let's go back because we we did we
had a we had found you know so it just
took you know and yet to be patient and
not get frustrated and you know and just
be you know because he is his vision I
wanted to help help me help you help me
help you I will say when you like today
watching it with my wife and you know
there is so much not talking these of
the dogs and the animators are really I
think they're like it's like real
magician a memory I mean I know magic is
real but like a other kind of it's like
magic I mean the fact that they are
there's a puppet that's this big you
know and little face and they goes that
and then take a picture in that take it
and then they're there they are and you
know Wes was saying that the the
animators they you the voices were so
helpful and you know they would listen
to them all the time and even when the
characters are not speaking like when I
see the film like I look at you know
Jeff's and I think that's there he's
alive and he's he's not in you know he
is that he's alive and to be able to put
life as something
is not talking for a lot of a movie is
incredible like if you just like I've
watched scenes just watch the you know
Bob Balaban and it's Bob out I mean it's
really spooky I'm bigger I'm bigger than
but you say the publisher like that be
well that there are puppets
there are puppets that are really little
for a wide super wide shots but how big
is Jim and then there's this can I tell
you another thing that's crazy I don't
have AB and I mean I don't know I'm not
the puppet master maybe someday but I
heard that Wes had to pick before the
film started roughly all the movements
that he thought the dogs that he would
need the dogs to make so that they could
build any of things specials were the
puppets to him you know the movements up
like each dog basically what what is
their range of motion gonna be do you
think you'll ever have them do this and
to do that and just select that up front
is I mean that seems very frightening I
mean it's really know the dogs truly
yeah and it's a yeah it's just I guess
so cuz you got to tell the puppet makers
yeah in this one I'm we're gonna need
that this one we don't need so much yeah
this one we're gonna need them but there
are various sizes I mean the baby the
baby dogs are tiny mm-hmm
I mean should they are smaller they're
smaller than the adult some small dogs
how ironic
yes well gentlemen I want to thank you
for being here and because just giving
us some insight in the film